there's a new study from Yale university,
the university of Florida and the university
of Maryland. And what this study says is that
transitioning to a single payer healthcare
system here in the United States would save
about $450 billion per year. It would save
the average family $2,400 a year and it would
prevent 68,000 unnecessary deaths representing
in total about a 13% savings in annual healthcare
costs with increased access. Now, you all
know that I've talked a lot about Medicare
for all and sometimes my commentaries about
Medicare for all, um, anger, some people in
the audience and typically those commentaries
are ones where I make clear that I support
Medicare for all. And I believe it may well
be the best system, but I believe that the
practical difficulties of making Medicare
for all a reality are often I'm a realist.
That's true. And a lot of people hear my realism
and they call me a defeatist. Now this is
a realist show. This is not a show that gives
you fantasies. So we discuss the difficulties
of policy and you might have noticed, maybe
you didn't that Congresswoman Alexandria Ocasio
Cortez recently similarly said, you know,
even if Bernie is elected, you don't just
wave a magic wand and get Medicare for all.
She wasn't attacked for saying basically the
same thing as I did. But that's another story.
Let's take some time today to in a non hyper-partisan
way think through this very good study, which
shows that Medicare for all would be cheaper
and it would prevent a lot of unnecessary
deaths. And let's apply it to our thinking
about healthcare altogether. There's a great
healthcare scholar who you've maybe heard
me mention before he passed away not long
ago. His name is [inaudible] Reinhardt.
Okay. And in his writing, [inaudible] would
explain that. When you look at healthcare,
there are essentially three factors to consider,
cost, access, and quality. Okay? If you pick
a certain healthcare cost, imagine you say
$100 billion is our healthcare costs. You
can then choose a balance between how much
access is there for 100 billion and how much
quality is there for 100 billion so to, to
make it visual. Imagine you have a slider.
It's that we have $100 billion to spend on
healthcare and you have a slider and you can
either give that hundred billion in healthcare
spending to one person, right? If you give
the a hundred billion to one person, you have
very low access. Only one person has healthcare,
but they're going to get everything they need
for that. $100 billion quality is going to
be absolutely huge. Or you go to the other
side and you say, well, let's give 5 billion
people coverage for that hundred a a billion
dollars in healthcare spending, and you can
imagine how now access has gone up to a hundred
percent but quality is going to go down and
you're not.
If you split the 100 billion among 5 billion
people, instead of giving it all to one person,
the quality of care is going to go down. Now,
that's an extreme example to get us thinking
in this sort of three metric mode, everybody
has healthcare, so now imagine a different
slider. We have a different slider called
100% access, okay? In this scenario, everybody
has healthcare, but now you've got a balance,
cost and quality, right? 100% access is fixed.
All else being equal. If you want quality
to be high with 100% access, you're going
to have higher costs. If you want costs to
be low under 100% access, then you are going
to have lower quality, right? If 5 billion
people get crappy care, you keep costs low
to give 5 billion people better care, costs
going to go up. So I think you get the idea,
these are the three metrics, cost, access
and quality and any health care program, I,
I, this isn't even yet about Medicare for
all.
Any system we have is going to somehow balance
cost, access and quality. If you don't change
the system, but you just give everybody access,
the only way to get it to cost less is to
reduce quality of care unless you fix other
things. And this is what's at the crux of
the Medicare for all debate. We say, Hey,
you know what? We can increase access and
we can keep quality the same or better. Well,
only if you deal with cost. If you don't deal
with the cost of the system, costs will go
up to keep the same quality and to give more
people healthcare. And so that's where you
get to a lot of the ways in which a program
like Medicare for all can actually reduce
costs without affecting quality necessarily.
So you can remove a lot of the middlemen that
inflate costs. You can take away the profit
part for health insurance companies, which
is actually relatively low.
You can eliminate all these multiple layers
of medical billing and bureaucracy and unnecessary
medical testing. You know, you can do all
that stuff. Um, but that's more of a gray
area. And the biggest criticism of most Medicare
for all plans is not, you know, from this
ideological it's socialism perspective that
those are dumb critiques. The serious critiques
of Medicare for all are that most of the plans
way too generously assume massive cost cuts
that they claim won't affect quality in order
to get everybody access without costing more
and without sacrificing quality. That gets
us to this new study. This new study says
we could transition to Medicare for all. We
will save $450 billion per year. We will save
68,000 people from unnecessary death and everybody
will get access. So when we go to our three
metrics, they are saying cost will go down
and access will go up.
They don't say anything about quality. So
the critique of this study is that it is not
realistic in terms of the quality of care
that will be provided. This is not my criticism.
This is the reality cost, access quality.
Unless you can explain here's how we reduce
costs in order to increase access without
reducing quality. This is how it works. These
are the three factors, factors and studies
that say you can get massive savings just
from making some small tweaks. You're often
only talking about a couple of percentage
points and case in point, this study has been
analyzed by the economic policy Institute
and the economic policy Institute said the
cost savings that are predicted are on the
high side. This is not a surprise to us. So
again, am I against a system like Medicare
for all? No, I'm for it. I'm for it.
I'm for it. I'm for Medicare for all. I'm
in favor of Medicare for all. What I'm telling
you is if you want to increase access to 100%
which I do, if you want to keep quality the
same or increase it, which I do, it most likely
is going to cost much more than what any candidate
is currently claiming. And that's okay. We
can say as a society it will cost more in
total, but you'll save premiums and copays.
We'll separate insurance from employers so
people don't have to tie their insurance to
a job. We'll reduce the cost per person. Rich
people will have to pay quite a bit more in
order to subsidize the system. In total, it
will cost more. I'm okay with that. I'm okay
because I think we need the same or better
quality than what we have now and we need
100% access.
I'm okay paying more. Uh, if that's what it
takes, but we need to understand the reality
of the plans and a lot of the plans are assuming
if we switch to Medicare for all American
healthcare costs, per capita will drop from
what they are here to what Australia or Canada
pay. That's not going to happen by making
the small tweaks that a lot of people are
talking about, it's going to require much,
much more. Yes, we've got to eliminate waste,
but to match the per capita costs of Australia
and Canada, eliminating wet waste just isn't
enough and we've got to figure that out and
we need to have answers because I want a system
like this. I hope that my analysis is making
sense. I want to hear from you. Remember I'm
for Medicare for all. If you're about to email
me and tell me how terrible it is that I'm
again a followed the David package.
Michelle show on Instagram at David Pakman
show. While you're there, follow me on Instagram
at David's